[Music]
what makes colombian music distinct i
mean it's it's got its own things i mean
it's got the importance of the accordion
um the thieple which you do not find
typically in in other forms of latin
music um the rhythms that are distinct
the vagina the rhythm is different from
a dominican meringue rhythm is different
from a diff puerto rican plana rhythm
there's just these subtle variations in
the instruments and and how they're
played it's important to get those right
you know that's that's that's the fun of
the specificity of writing music for
this region
within cantos you've got a lot of family
members i think with every musical
project i embark on i'm trying to find
the pulse of the characters first and
foremost what is mirabelle's pulse how
is that different from abuela's pulse
how is that different from bruno's pulse
how is that different from pepa's pulse
there are songs that are solo journeys
you know when you hear from mirabelle's
sister luisa it's a very contemporary
colombian regetong sound
because she's got this very cool very
tough exterior and then i wanted to sort
of peel away and deconstruct that over
the course of the song
and then you have isabella who sounds
like 90s rock and espanol and then in
the last song i'm smashing those themes
together that's the fun of building a
musical score is when you find all those
pulses and then you start to have them
sing in duets and trios really
interesting combinations and stuff start
to pop up the whole movie has this
beautiful tapestry that feels like a
very unique hole that couldn't have come
from any other place all of that
together has created something that is
really unique and really special
and very specific i think both to region
and also the experiences of the
characters throughout the movie
every song in this is going to be
something you want to like listen to on
the radio and like dance in your living
room too because all of them have like
amazing beats they're really
poppy and stand out it doesn't sound
like any other disney movie
we were incredibly lucky to find
jermaine franco to do the score for this
film
early on we had initial discussions
about what type of score they were
looking for and we talked about what
would the sound of magical realism sound
like you read the stories of gabrielle
garcia marquez and you go into those
worlds and you think how
would what would this sound like the
first time
jermaine played us
the main theme of the encanto of
that magic i think the first thing we
said was that sounds like magical
realism
[Music]
i wanted to find
lavos
the feminine voice of the music of
colombia because i feel that the voice
of the latina woman is very important in
our society in our world because a lot
of women in latin america have been
shouldering a lot of responsibility of
working and taking care of their
families and i wanted to give that
struggle and the persistence and the
courage some sort of a voice
through the music
[Music]
we were certainly aware of her amazing
work on
coco but one of the things that jermaine
specializes in is blending all these
different styles of music and different
instrumentation into something truly
wonderful this tapestry that we needed
for in concha and kanto's soundtrack to
the point where she actually was
ordering handcrafted marimbas from
colombia just for
encounter
that she was unpacking the week of the
score recording which was incredible the
fact she takes so much care uh in what
she does and someone who had some so
much personal investment in talking
about this family in a musical way
what i did was just imagine a world
beyond the world we live in now and it's
like there's another
plane and so in this in this world in
the story
people have magical powers and so it's
it's almost like another dimension of
sounds
[Music]
[Music]
a hugely challenging song and
we told lin in a matter of just a few
minutes the audience has to understand
everyone in this family and the magical
gifts needs to understand what they do
for the community and it had to be crazy
entertaining
nearly every cast member is actually
part of a chorus and it's a great show
piece from mirabella because mirabella
is singing this song and so her
personality comes out
[Music]
is an amazing singer and an amazing
actress and it's been so exciting to
write to her voice which is incredibly
musical and bubbly and uh just kind of
perfect for mirabelle i am such a big
disney fan and i grew up with this music
and i grew up singing songs to myself in
my mirror when i was a kid the whole
thing felt really surreal what's your
gift and she goes let me recap
[Music]
it starts with abuela and then pepe she
handles the weather my mom julietta can
make you feel better with just one area
it gets faster and faster and faster and
that was really fun to construct this
incredible verbal fuselage but it's all
about avoiding the issue and that's a
really great way to reveal character
[Music]
[Music]
i was really inspired by carlos vivas
music and then to actually have carlos
vives sing the song i wrote inspired by
his work and his genre was just sort of
the icing on the cake
[Music]
this is a party song you know by yanatos
or what we put on at parties so i wanted
to just write the most joyous song
possible and so it's the lyrics are all
just sort of a love letter to this house
to this part of the world and to
colombia itself to have the person who
brought vinod to the world be in this
movie is just just incredible that was
just a joy beginning to end to write and
then it gets ratcheted up to the nth
degree when you have carlos's vocals and
his incredible musicians on top
[Applause]
[Music]
luisa also has one of the most fun songs
of the
[Music]
as the crust movie the earth is
okay once we've identified where the
moments are that the characters emotions
are kind of too big for words and need
to have music then we hand it over to
lin-manuel and he
turns it into an amazing song
[Music]
luisa who is accustomed to bearing
everyone's burdens that is sort of a
fantastical outgrowth of something that
i think plagues a lot of oldest siblings
in families and so musicalizing that was
really exciting and so i wrote a
regetong song called surface pressure
and it was about how she's very cool on
the surface and there's nothing she can
handle but under it
there's all this stuff
[Music]
so i just wrote the most wild and crazy
internal rhymes and then exposed how
much louisa longs to relax
but wait
if i could shake
the crushing weight
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe i overdo it
yep
[Music]
all right so are we starting at um jared
had worked with lynn on moana before i
had never met him i was a huge admirer
of his work but i i didn't know how the
experience would be working with him but
the amazing thing is that he's such an
amazing collaborator and once he locks
onto something how quickly he can come
up with something brilliant there was
one call we were on i don't know i think
it was to talking about um bruno's song
we don't talk about bruno and he
literally said okay it's sort of a sort
of a spooky
ghost story and he kind of turns it
literally into the piano and does
what you tell us exactly what you hear
in the bruno song like dun
[Music]
dun he just played it and it was like oh
okay well that's done so he literally
kind of came up with that in in seconds
and then he would disappear for a week
or so and come back with this incredible
demo
[Music]
look at my hair
we don't talk about bruno is the family
gossip song that was really exciting
because every verse and every stanza we
got to meet a different character and
they're all kind of riding the same
musical landscape but they ride it
completely differently this is awesome
hello i wrote dolores first she's got
this very hushed quiet little patter
section you know
and they kind of took the ball and ran
with that
living fear of bruno stuttering or
stumbling i can always hear him sort of
muttering and mumbling i associate him
with the sound of fallen sands
[Music]
one of the sequences that highlights
choreography the most and jamal sims our
choreographer did an absolutely
incredible job creating something so
physical incorporating dances of
colombia and to see peppa and felix
like singing about this mysterious guy
while doing these beautiful dance moves
and jamal also worked with kai who is
colombian and so there's a lot of
colombian dance that's incorporated
within the amazing choreography
diving into it let's go let's do it
that's great
when i got into the room with kai and
then we also had a group of latino and
latina skeleton dancers it started to
come together
[Music]
i had the funnest time working on this
particular sequence just because of the
spirit of all of us in the room together
we started vibing and all of a sudden
i'll be like oh let's do this and kyle
would be like oh but let's try it like
that
[Music]
it was that collaborative effort that i
think was really magical and also lynn
manuel made the story easy as well
because the way he wrote that song all
you had to do is just let it take you
and you just go along for the ride
[Applause]
[Music]
there was a point where we figured out
that alma abuela alma needed to tell us
her story in a song what i really wanted
to do was kind of write a song that felt
like it always existed a very campesino
feeling folk song and so in looking at
the imagery for the film when the most
beautiful things is when abuela's
kendall becomes a butterfly
so i decided to write a song called
dosorogitas it means two caterpillars
and it's about two caterpillars who are
in love and are scared to let go of each
other but they have to let go of each
other otherwise they don't get to go to
their next form it's about letting go so
the miracle can happen
[Music]
when you do voice over you definitely
got to approach whatever it is you're
doing different than when you are a
singer or a songwriter working on your
own album which it's like you express
everything the way you wanted to because
you're yourself now here you're an actor
[Music]
and about how they had to change they
had to lean into the scariest things for
the next thing to happen and how that's
sort of the lesson for abuela one of the
things that was really moving to me was
that sebastian is about the same age as
pedro was on alma and he first began
their relationship
i can't hear that song and not tear up i
just think it's a beautiful song i love
the journey it takes you on and how
intimate it sounds i think it's the real
departure from things we may have done
in the past and i love it
sings it so beautifully the storytelling
is so crystal clear it gives me chills
to hear him sing it
i have to dig deep and feel what he's
feeling that is fun for me because you
start singing the song a certain way and
then you just start molding it into
something that has a little part of you
but it's not you it's him
[Music]
the musical real estate is so precious
and so to try to get as much colombian
music into the film
is not an easy ask and we sweated every
detail
both in the visuals of the film and in
the musical diversity of the film to
make sure
that colombia itself felt seen and
represented from the beginning we wanted
to just put something out to the world
that would bring them different types of
music the music of encanto should really
surprise people whatever you think the
music is going to be in a movie like
this it will not be that
[Music]